mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wer kultur
viel vergnügen corona frosta die party
los turi die isolation der lockdown
wochen ist vorbei wir wollen wieder
freunde treffen miteinander lachen
tanzen
unser lebenshunger ist zurück wir fragen
heute wie geht feiern trotz kurier ein
kulturplatz auch zur lebenslust
[Musik]
wir kommen aus dem kulturplatz heute
machen sie station in der zürcher
langstrasse
noch ist es tag aber der abend wird
kommen und damit auch die lust endlich
wieder auszugehen das leben
zur feier
nur das zusammengehen pandemie und
partylaune das fragen wir heute und auch
wie überleben die menschen im
gastgewerbe diese krise hier machen
station in einer war die wurde dank
corona zu einer blühenden oase kommen
sie mit
[Musik]
bonbon
der olé olé war tanzt der bär
normalerweise aber heute ist montag und
heute ist auch immer noch corona
besondere umstände also wie die
betreiberinnen dieser war in der krise
neue wege suchen dazu später mehr jetzt
gleich setzen wir zuerst den fokus
darauf wie können wir feiern trotz
corona in massen anstatt in maßen gegen
das abstandsgebot party als wäre corona
geschichte und die gefahr des virus
gebannt die sonne scheint der sommer ist
da jung und alt zieht es nach draußen
genug zu hause geblieben
sie wollen das leben wieder genießen
gemeinsam mit freunden bekannten und
liebsten lebenslust und ausgelassene
stimmung
la dolce vita festen und feiern mit 20
jahren noch beinahe lebenswichtig wie
übersteht man corona mit geschlossenen
clubs und ohne party wir haben eine
unserer millennials gefragt die anfang
jahr einen kulturplatz mitgestaltet
haben eigentlich die energie wo nichts
mix up artist oder so ursula hahn und
ich noch völlig platt in die hitze zum
andere sachen machen kann ich wirklich
lust drauf haben und nicht nur was mir
ab heute wird angeschmissen wird oder so
feiern bis zum abwinken daniel späth die
hat nach den gründen für das überangebot
an events geforscht und ein buch zur
eventkultur zürichs mitverfasst und
[Musik]
jetzt geht wie ruhm für für office wo
man nicht wissen was es ist wohl die
initiative gri vielleicht unsere
leidenschaft herzblut wo sich für die
vor ort organisieren mit kommerzieller
seiner heim party im livestream ein buch
ohne türsteher und schlange stehen aus
dem wohnzimmer direkt live ins netz
aufgebrezelt frisch frisiert mit glitzer
und glamour party die alternative aus
dem fitnessstudio mit laser und lichter
show oder aus dem zürcher schauspielhaus
mit digitalem dj könnte dürfte wohl gut
sitzender bis machen dass das alte holz
nicht in konstanz oder sozialen oder zur
flucht oder sozialer ort also dass man
dies bildet wo er bis startet wo die
community gedanke wieder trieb
nachtschwärmer an fehlt nun der
existentielle lebensraum die clubs
deshalb entwerfen manuel fischer und
sein kreativ studio eine art welche die
analoge und digitale welt vereint und
zur entdeckung einlädt egal wo man ist
ob in zürich new york oder shanghai
mit der app kann man mit feiern raven
als avatar
als virtuelles wesen im corona sicheren
outfit den alltag vergessen die zürcher
partyszene lotet gerade die grenzen des
digitalen aus eine andere idee gibt es
im klub kautz brauchle ein stammgast hat
seinen lieblingsort in zürich nachgebaut
virtuell
lampe sind eigentlich die größte vortrag
sich vor allem die verstärkte damit ein
kapitäns wirklich glaube begrüßt und
bastler stück für stück mit leidenschaft
und sorgfalt dj-pult und bar für
feierfreudige im virtuellen raum pure
verzweiflung will mir die zweite stufe
klostersee ist und dann hatte ich
eigentlich für ganz dringende bis machen
und hatte gefundenen leichen in konstanz
sie haben könne sich weiter an die macht
kam ein größeres diverse rausgeholt habe
ist stark sie begegnungen mit anderen
schreiben oder reden wie am telefon
der klub für zu hause vom sofa aus doch
was ist mit fetten beats und
sinnesrausch endorphin erfüllt aus dem
klub taumeln werden wir künftig ohne
diesel nächte lieben es kritik weil man
die tendenz dass crysis auch online welt
stattfinde ob das wird von mir
er setzte das dass man sich mit und
physisch will sagt alice hinaus spricht
im prinzip und online ist das einfach
nicht mögen
das hat jetzt das tanzfestival gegen
winterthur es war soweit online
stattgefunden hat und die hand
livestreams gemacht zum teil einer
ganzen tag lang aber die zwerge hat mich
eigentlich vorschreibt ruhiger gemacht
weil ich okay sich jetzt im studio das
mache ich ein zoologe aber ich freue
mich mache dann schaut man sich die
stube des bayer und dann steht eine wand
und so ist sich schwer
das hat mich vor nichts leben
melancholisch bestimmt ab 6 juni gibt es
wieder möglichkeiten im kleineren rahmen
zu verheeren zwei meter abstandsregel
inbegriffen
[Musik]
so mit gebührendem abstand
sony und lg sind betreiberin der olé olé
waren normale wiesn ort muss extrem
brummt und vor nicht allzu langer zeit
haben wir von 100 auf null aber fahrer
wie ist das ziel ist es ist schlimm
schockmomente krasniqi bis zum lockt mit
der angst und macht es nach neumarkt
kühlschrank stellen zwei wochen ablaufen
kann der existenzielle sorgen konnte der
einbrecher nach arbeit mache ihr anteil
ausmachen gesellschaften könnten aber
die chemie zwischen verstand was er
zahlen teilten mit man könne jetzt
wieder erhöht gewesen
die existenzielle angst gehabt und ihnen
jetzt täglich wird für den moment für
für jetzt so wie es jetzt läuft nämlich
ein witz wie barbetrieb die haben eine
originelle idee kam mit einer puppe dass
man sieht überhaupt wo darf man sieht
sofort wie viel man stellvertreterin
herzte moment das waren alle vier
drücken würde ich sagen zwölfmal hand
durch eine linie vermissen der 2
durchsagen maximal 18 kapazitäten 18 und
hat eine besondere umstand wir sind dann
im normalen betrieb viel polizeilich
ziemlich verwundert haben gelernt über
80 ihnen das muss noch ein durchkommen
[Musik]
als normal aber vergessen will es
genießen wir zu euch und den bringt nix
mit dem wunsch als maske ist das ein
widerspruch in sich
aber darauf mit dem auftrag ist
freiwillig mit dem zu strenge
vorschriften auch damit haben die es
infizieren will spezifizieren
in der theorie stimmt
nicht nur bar und club szene ist micron
eine totale krise gestürzt auch er ist
ein profi journalismus ist es schwierig
sei nach wie vor richtig und so fällt
die krebs führen
[Musik]
journalismus lebt seit jeher von der
hautnahen recherche der unerschrockenen
ermittlung von vertraulichen gespräch im
trend bleiben
mitten drin sein berührungsängste frei
gute journalisten sind ja eigentlich
exzellent die beobachter als das sind
die evus verstehen da auch komplizierte
sachverhalte linie szene sich leeres
beschrieben also äußerst schafft das ist
begegnet mit mancher das ist auch der
dialog die auseinandersetzung mit
äußerung war doch das virus hat auch da
den stillstand erzwungen und traf damit
den journalismus mitten ins mark
für den reporter im home-office vor
allem aber auch für freie journalisten
war es ein harter schnitt die vierte
gewalt in quarantäne
die kollegin kollegen besetzt und die
sorge um die vielfalt der
berichterstattung
denn ist doch eine aseptische safer
journalismus ein widerspruch in sich
die korona regeln wurden zu hürden
selbst für furchtlose investigative
journalisten rund um den globus
verunmöglichen manch informelles
hintergrundgespräch
ganz viele informanten bevölkerung ist
natürlich wenn man sich sozusagen unter
vier augen trifft weil viele informant
einfach die sorge haben dass wenn man
telefoniert dass das wort verfügbar ist
und das macht es recherchieren ganz
bestimmt schwieriger wird es niemals
sagen dass diese maßnahmen die wir
beschlossen worden sind um die berühmte
kurse abzuflachen
dass diese waren aber das ist eben auch
ein kollateralschaden würde ich sagen
das ist regionalisten dafür
investigativer müssen schwieriger
geworden ist zu arbeiten und ist doch
gerade in krisen momenten kritischer und
glaubwürdiger journalismus gefragter
denn je
in zeiten großer unsicherheit das
verlangen nach orientierung immens ist
informationsbedürfnis natürlich riesig
simanski welche funktionen premier
league sie vom erkläre vom informieren
auch zahlen aufbereitet zu visualisieren
und das hat man gesehen also die zahler
sind rekordhoch sind nur büro ist
übrigens weltweit und man hat er schon
können sie das detail die informationen
wo sich das virus treten
das los genau in dieser herausfordernden
zeit ist den medien zusätzlich der
werbemarkt regelrecht weggebrochen und
diese gelder wird vermutet kommen nicht
wieder richtig zu wirken
das verlangt nach neuen strukturen ob
gar gebührenfinanzierter journalismus
daraus wird payrolls mit senaten tun
was ist das bezahlmodell der zukunft an
innovativen medien modellen wird schon
lange getüftelt
jetzt sind die karten auf dem tisch und
er ein medienpionier sieht sich in
seiner stets portierten meinung
bestätigt
roehler hat offenbart dass kreisklasse
geschäftsmodell medical journal ist also
die verlagshäuser dem kai zukunftsvision
oder und das heißt eigentlich braucht
trotzdem unabhängiger journalismus mit
das anders gestalte es ist mit
journalismus wird man nie mehr
wahnsinnig viel geld verdienen aber wir
brauchen trotzdem unter der villa vom
staat verordnet oder sagte sie
wird es den reichen dass die
journalisten die macher ihre arbeit von
leserinnen und lesern direkt bezahlt
bekommen sei ein zukunftsmodell das
online medium wie beispielsweise ist
werbefrei member und stiftungsgelder
gestützt und lokal verankert tritt zahlt
aus die mit mir journalismus machen und
sich auf neue sie eben halt und das ich
bin das geschäftsmodell heißt
identifikation als zukunftsbranche
journalismus und täters in ab jetzt ganz
einfach china am start
eine handvoll online projekte gehen das
wagnis derzeit rein tragen zur vielfalt
in der schweizer medienlandschaft bei
die wurde so viel ist sicher von der
pandemie auch tüchtig durchgeschüttelt
und gefordert und profit 19 hat dem
umbruchs prozess dem wandel einen schub
verpasst
[Musik]
neue formen also eigentlich b das wesen
ja die pflicht der vierten gewalt im
kern bleibt es dasselbe aufdecken
kommentieren einordnen
auch unangenehme fragen stellen und
wichtig dies immer mit kritischer
distanz
[Musik]
der zwist im blumenmeer und genau das
ist doch corona geht es da an
blumenladen und floristik fuchs hat ist
es schwierig sie etwas mitbringen wir
sind grundsätzlich bis zu klagen
ich glaube da manche probieren das ist
ganz wichtig wir haben jetzt da einfach
mal ausprobiert dann wahrscheinlich
das ist das spiralschloss also bei
umsätzen von taxis muss ich sagen wie
ist denn das wieso sind wir überhaupt
durch die idee planung der bauer das ist
jetzt nicht ganz genau
wir haben wir euch schon morgen wieder
in blumenrath um 18 jahren und eine
stola chrome hat die wird man mich
einkaufen und dann haben wir gefunden
jetzt waren dann und dann haben wir das
gemacht und es zeit fürs auge es ist
fantastisch schöner dem ort das blutbad
ich würde sagen das muss unbedingt
bleiben seid ihr das neue
wie findet schön würde das gern
weiterziehen will mir fehlen jetzt
blumen und dort hat sich eine weitere
haben zusammen einen slogan für
hydraulik an gott und römerstraße zu
bringen er ist jetzt haben eine erste
spur
[Musik]
von hier aus stellen wir hier in eine
große literaten vor die irische
schriftstellerin hella o'brien eine
frühe kämpferin für die emanzipation und
jetzt hat sie einen erschütternden roman
geschrieben darin schaut sie nach
nigeria und erzählt von einem der 200
schulmädchen die im april vor sechs
jahren von terroristen entführt wurden
die welt hat diese katastrophe längst
vergessen
ryan nicht nigeria seit zehn jahren
bietet im nordosten die islamistische
terror miliz boko haram ein krieg vor
allem gegen mädchen und frauen mehr als
2000 sollen es sein die entführt wurden
dazu massenflucht über 20.000 tote
keine region die man einfach so bereist
sie tat es etwa o'brien irische
schriftstellerin eine lady 89 nervös war
ich ja aber fest entschlossen nichts
konnte mich davon abhalten
ich dachte ich fahre da hin und werde
herausfinden was da passiert
die hochbegabte in london leben der
o'brien reiste nach nigeria um für ein
buch zu recherchieren das anders ist als
alles was in den letzten 60 jahren
geschrieben hat das mädchen 2014 hatte
boko haram über 200 schülerinnen in
georg hinführt zwei jahre später las
o'brien von einem mädchen das der
gefangenschaft in fliehen konnte
monatelang allein im urwald lebte diese
nachricht ließ sie nicht mehr los
ich berührte diese menschliche dimension
in ihrer ganzen unmenschlichkeit die
grausamkeit der geschichte ließ mich
nicht mehr los
ob ryan 1930 in irland geboren sorgte
mit ihrem debüt-roman 1960 für einen
skandal bekannt erzählt von der
lebenslust junger frauen im
erzkatholischen irlands und wurde
verbrannt die weiteren romanen irland
verboten
sie wurde zur vorkämpferin der
emanzipation und gibt jetzt als
wichtigste autorin irlands
nigerianerinnen eine stimme die welt
soll ihre geschichte kenne sie verdienen
in zwei langen aufenthalten machte sie
sich auf die suche nach
entführungsopfern von boko haram wollte
wissen wie er leben weitergeht reiste
mit dolmetscher durch ein ihr fremdes
land sprach mit journalisten nonnen und
ärzten die opferbetreuung und fand
zugang zu frauen denen aus eigener kraft
die flucht aus den lagern der terror
miliz gelungen war
jedes treffen näherte ihren roman da war
zum beispiel dieses 1
sie war so still traumatisiert auch noch
jahre nach der entführung allein an der
art wie sie da saß konnte ich sehen will
schuldig sie sich fühlte dass sie es
geschafft hatte zu entfliehen
aber viele nicht brian verwebt diese
zeugenberichte zu einer fiktiven
geschichte
maria
massen vergewaltigt dem terror lager der
boko haram zwangsverheiratet es klafft
zugerichtet von den männern
es wird eine metzelei an mir verübt sie
bekommt ein baby und weiß nicht ob sie
es jemals wird lieben kann
sie sind kinder mädchen des krieges für
sie ist krieg nicht nur beim bern
es ist einfacher zu schießen als ständig
vergewaltigt zu werden
ihre körper werden als waffe missbraucht
ihre seelen auch marian entkommt ihren
folter nach einem luftangriff des
militärs wird mit ihrem baby durch den
st dieser wald rückzugsgebiet von boko
haram monate lang
wird bei ihrer rückkehr zum
vorzeigeobjekt der nigerianischen
regierung
doch für ihre familie und die
gemeinschaft ist sie eine putzfrau
eine schande ihr baby ein kind des
feindes zunächst freuen sich die eltern
ihre mädchen zu sehen
aber die meisten nehmen ihre töchter
nicht mehr zu hause auf denn das dorf
ist misstrauisch
viele schicken ihre töchter weg in die
städte wo sie in der anonymität
verschwinden sollen diese
stigmatisierung macht die mädchen gleich
zwei mal zu opfern
die große alte dame hat sich in die
geschichte dieser jungen frauen
hineingeschrieben ihren langen weg
zurück ins leben
intensiv glasklar poetisch ihren roman
hat sie den müttern und töchtern nordost
nigerias gewidmet
[Musik]
würde ich den mädchen die ich traf und
denen die ich nicht getroffen
aus meinem roman vorlesen sie wie rooney
giggs davon in zweifel ziehen
sie hätte sich so bequem machen können
mit fast 90
doch schonen will sie sich nicht uns
auch nicht etwa brain die unbeirrbare
[Musik]
hier darf momentan nicht gedrückt werden
zu viele hände waren beim spiel deshalb
ist die jukebox der olé olé momentan im
urlaub viele hände sind auch dann im
spiel wenn sängerinnen und sänger großes
leisten wenn etwa die walliser rockröhre
tina auf der bühne glänzt dann ist das
immer auch den sogenannten side mann zu
verdanken brillante musiker die kaum
einer kennt diesen schlüsselfiguren
widmet die sternstunde musik kommenden
pfingstsonntag einen film
anlass für uns zu fragen wie steht es in
der musikbranche die ja von corona auch
nachhaltig und hart getroffen ist
[Musik]
sie gehören seit jahrzehnten zu den
begehrtesten begleitmusikern der schweiz
sowie von dach und hendrix ab der neue
dokumentarfilm sideman ist eine
poetische hommage an diese und andere
begleitmusiker wer sind sie
zwischen teil 1 und teil der band
[Musik]
die spieler das sind alles aufbauen
das ist riskant
ich liebe zur musik
womöglich von dach auf tour mit siena
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hendrix adler auf der bühne mit philipp
fankhauser
seit 16 jahren arbeiten sie zusammen
seit mann ist ein film über musiker die
meist im schatten der stars stehen und
mit ihrem talent die stars doch erst
richtig zum leuchten bringen natürlich
sternchen nabu ruft er sieht dass das
stimmt aber das ist für mich nicht nur
ein teil für meine familie von ihnen
musikalische sondern eine ganz wichtige
musikalische stücke handys dieser größe
wie haben wir als größter bezeugt wie
musik für hendrik rolle als musiker und
künstler ist
und dann das
[Musik]
corona krise blog down und stillstand
des öffentlichen lebens konzert und
veranstaltungs verbote auf unbestimmte
zeit für live musiker heißt das über
nacht keine auftritte mehr was nun eine
grußbotschaft auf der küche
[Musik]
von dach und partnerin gegen motor auch
sie musikerin müssen seit wochen die
gürtel enger schnallen
links und rechts und sowas gibt es ja
irgendwie musik italien hofft gestärkt
und eine aussage ich gar nicht dass man
schön blüht das lied so etwas ja unser
beruf bedingt michael hüther sieht dass
man seine musiker vorspiel also das
große wort für den musiker
[Musik]
als selbständiger musiker hat vom dach
anrecht auf staatliche finanzhilfe die
selbständige also ich bin jetzt sieht
nun hoch kann ich keinen rappen verdient
und das wissen sie meinte jedoch trüben
mündet ohne einkommen aber ich bin ohne
vorstoß gemacht das ich haben militär
spielt familie mit
[Musik]
wenn ich mir das vorstellen dass das so
lange albert mit den jungs natürlich
oder mobil über das kann den roaming
also und dann muss möglicherweise denkt
musik als eine idee stößt wurf geschafft
oder wieder zurückgebildet
ich kann musikwoche gitarre spielen aber
wahrscheinlich von den augen des abreden
nach alternativen spielen bis zum
umfallen
[Musik]
im kleinen musikland schweiz werden auch
die erfolgreichsten zeit man nicht reich
aber leben davon können sie allemal
corona hat die lage verändert nur
vorübergehend bleibt zu hoffen dass war
unser besuch an der zürcher langstrasse
da wo die blumen blühen nächste woche da
suchen und finden wir dass mehr in der
schweiz gleich jetzt folgt die britische
serie bodyguard kommen
er war damals
[Musik]
kaum ist
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
tourismus
[Applaus]